Batman and Superman of the two seminal
iconic characters of comic mythology
this is the Alpha and Omega of this
world there are a number of different
ways that we evolve both Batman and
Bruce Wayne in this movie he's older
darker more world-weary twenty years in
Gotham and made good guys are left and
they stayed that way I really like this
Batman there's something brutal and
unforgiving tell me do you played at all
two people who both consider themselves
good guys come into conflict with one
another he has the power to wipe out the
entire human race I'm gonna have to
destroy an
everyone has grown up having their
heroes and there aren't two who are
better now and then Superman a Batman we
need these kind of characters bare the
people who bring light to get rid of the
dark
I was excited about fusing the Superman
world with the world of Batman
Superman has made the leap and now he's
out there for everyone to call judgment
on he's starting to see that every
action has a reaction there's no such
thing as just being good all the time
he's still trying to do the right thing
and do the right thing by everyone and
ignore the slings and arrows the world
has been so caught up with what Superman
can do no one has asked what he should
do at the same time try and get a closer
connection to humanity I think that
Clark experiences a little bit of the
broken heartedness of being human being
people hate what they don't understand
when it comes to Batman Superman doesn't
agree with the way he carries out
justice his viewers go about it in an
ethical manner where Batman is at any
cost inflict justice and so that's
essentially where they come to blows
excuse me
the other night you took something that
doesn't belong me stealing is not my
life is it stealing if you steal from
another teeth who are you
someone interested in the same man you
are today right the data a carpet is
military-grade encryption you know I bet
with that dress
9 out of 10 men know that you get away
with hiring but you're the devil I'm
guessing I'm gonna first see through
that babe in the woods act you don't
know me but I don't know what she
wouldn't like you know I don't think
you've ever known a woman like me and
now you will fly to him and you will
battle him to the death
black and blue fight night the greatest
gladiator match in the history of the
world God versus man day versus night
Son of Krypton versus bat of Gotham
you're gonna go to war and suffer it
brought the war to us two years ago
Jesus Alfred counted dead thousands of
people
what's next Millions he has the power to
wipe out the entire human race and if we
believe there's even a 1% chance that he
is our enemy we have to take it as an
absolute certainty no I have to destroy
him but he is not our enemy
not today 20 years in Gotham alpha we've
seen what promises are worth how many
good guys are left how many stayed that
way
hey youtubers is Charlie we're almost a
Batman V Superman a whole bunch of stuff
just dropped so let's break it down the
most interesting clip I think besides
all the behind the scenes stuff which is
always fascinating to me is the scene
that Batman has with Wonder Woman where
he's talking about women he's known
before like her women who steal things I
was just like oh my god he must be
talking about Catwoman and if he's been
Batman for at least 20 years he's
probably run into all of his rogues
gallery and they did say that the
extended cut of the film like the
director's cut is an extra 30 minutes so
we might see a lot of Easter eggs for
all the stuff that he's done in those 20
years that the attribute cut will still
be about two and a half hours I don't
know how long it's gonna be before we
get to see that director's cut maybe by
the end of the summer because Suicide
Squad is coming out after Comic Con
they're mostly gonna be promoting that
movie for the rest of the year but they
might also choose to drop that extended
cut around that time of the year like
around the time Suicide Squad is ramping
up and really good news because I forgot
to do one in my earlier videos this week
there's a new DC giveaway that starts
now it's just a $20 Amazon gift card or
you know what let's do movie passes
it'll be a gift certificate for the
equivalent of two imax tickets for
Batman V Superman in the giveaway will
stay open till I post my flash video on
Tuesday all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video normally any format you see
the movie and should be fine but just
look at this scene real quick and you'll
see what you miss if you don't see the
movie in IMAX
so definitely go for IMAX if you have
the opportunity but here we go
Superman of course addressing the idea
that he's getting [ __ ] on even though
he's saving people no matter what he
does it tends to get misinterpreted so
like Zack Snyder says there's no such
thing as just being a good person and
that's the end of the story because I
watched so many things and read so many
comics I tend to draw parallels between
characterizations like you talked about
the way Batman vs Superman is
characterizing the Superman character is
actually very similar to what's going on
with arrow and Oliver Queen they save
the city and still get [ __ ] on Batman in
the movie is adored by the Gotham Police
Department just like Barry on the flash
TV show is loved by the city
despite actually causing some collateral
damage every once in a while it's really
funny because in terms of tonality
Barry's supposed to be the Superman
Oliver supposed to be the Batman but I
don't want to talk about it too much in
this video because this is mostly Batman
V Superman but there's actually some
really cool Justice Society stuff
happening on arrow that I'll talk about
in a video later this week
moving to the behind-the-scenes stuff
there's actually some fun Easter eggs a
lot of it is from footage that you've
already seen so I'm actually gonna skip
to the stuff that we haven't really seen
before look at the stuff that alfred is
working on that doesn't look like a
Batman helmet it looks a little bit too
small I'm wondering if he has some sort
of drone because there's limited time to
tell story there's a lot of things that
they do visually like they tell visual
stories so any time we're in the Batcave
you see things like the Robin suit and
it tells a story that they don't
necessarily explain overtly during the
film but just like in the comic books
there are a bunch of Easter eggs for
Batman's past adventures there will
probably be a lot of that inside this
Batcave I'm not expecting the giant
penny or the dinosaur though this is
where Bruce's parents are buried his
father is actually being played by
Jeffrey Dean Morgan who will be seen in
some kind of flashback which is funny
because he's playing negan on the
walking dead completely different ends
of the spectrum in terms of characters
here's another really fun Easter egg
doesn't that name look familiar
there's even an arrow pointing towards
the name nice Jack Nicholson hat tip
where does he get all those wonderful
toys and here's actually a good shot of
Ben Affleck with only part of his armor
on that gives you an idea just how big
it is Henry
actually said because he can barely see
when he has the helmet on he would trip
all the time just walking around the set
so I'll also say be careful for spoilers
from the film there are people around
the world that will be seeing it before
other people so there's probably gonna
be a lot of stuff flooding the internet
on Monday what I want to do next week
because I'm not gonna see the movie
until Thursday so I'll be posting a
non-spoilery review video Thursday night
and then I'll do like a spoilery Easter
egg video on Friday before that I might
do a bonus video for Justice League or a
kryptonite or just something fun from
the Batman or Superman universe be sure
to subscribe to get that if there's
anything specific you guys want before
the movie comes out just let me know but
I won't be doing any spoilery stuff till
way way late next week so don't worry
about that just get really hype about
them paying reference to some of the
most iconic Superman Batman moments in
the comics because there's so much
daredevil stuff happening this week I'm
a little behind on other videos my Game
of Thrones video that I normally be
posting on Sunday is just gonna post on
Monday I will be doing a new Walking
Dead episode later tonight so be sure to
look out for that
lots of Marvel stuff happening this
weekend because of daredevil but also
really like next week is the big DC week
why you guys wait for my next video to
post you can click here for my first
daredevil Easter Egg video and you can
click here for all my Batman V Superman
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight